j'ai beaucoup aimé cette maison de
sciences po
j'ai aussi des professeurs exceptionnels
et je m'étais acheté arrivé trop tard
parce que vous savez on s'inscrit à
sciences po en première année et puis
comme j'étais parti aux états unis je
suis arrivé in extremis là dessus on m'a
dit reste une un maître de conférences
tous les autres sont pris les plus
connus tout il s'appelle chirac alors
moi j'ai dit bon ben je pense chirac
j'ai pas le choix toute façon j'aimerais
et c'est vrai que je jacques chirac m'a
beaucoup frappé il a été mon maître de
conférences à sciences po et c'est
quelqu'un qui qui sûrement et beaucoup
d' influence sur moi et souvent que
c'est un peu comme à comme un maître il
faut savoir qu'il était tout jeune il
est moi j'avais 17 ans il en avait 28
ce qui me frappait beaucoup c'est son
dynamisme
sa manière de
d'être avec les étudiants extrêmement
comment dire vaillant en quelque sorte
et
était au
fond
tout le monde était très très conquis
par nuit par sa manière d'être et c'est
très très frappant enfants moi j'ai
mangé une femme honnête avec lui et c
deja qu on appelait les notes de
conférence mais il était il pouvait être
une idée très sévère
n'a pas été avec moi j'ai de la chance
un de mes amis qui qui était d'une
charmante jeune femme qui sortait
jusqu'à 3 heures du matin qui arrivait
avec les yeux tirer comme ça chirac dit
mademoiselle quand on porte le nom vous
partez on n'a pas le droit de défiler
ses études il ya même une note
éliminatoire de conférences de méthode
donc il pourrait être sévère mais il
était super dynamique rien que sur sa
manière de marcher dans les couloirs de
sciences mans ouvriers ils
n'arriveraient que ces grands pas et
sert à l'heure pile il était comme ça
donc moi il m'a beaucoup
beaucoup appris
je dirais justement dans dans la
politique de la france tout simplement
dans
également la politique étrangère
et l'été il était très très présent dans
tous ces domaines or il y avait des
choses amusantes avec chirac c'est que
quand il y avait un étudiant qui posait
une question un petit peu comme on dit
un petit peu je dirais pas
insidieusement fait un petit peu
un petit peu précise un petit peu
assommante or chirac récit de phrase
extraordinaire passons sur les détails
et remettez à sa place les étudiants qui
avaient voulu les grilles cassé un peu
les pieds mais je les bien connus que
j'ai connu en première année ensuite
dans seconde année à sciences po ge
était son assistant et puis par la suite
vers vu dans un temps à l'elysée ici
c'est vraiment quelqu'un que j'ai
beaucoup d'avenir est
bien aussi son épouse je connais un
petit peu la famille et une histoire ses
entrepôts de son épouse c'est que quand
on est élu il a été élu
au conseil municipal de sainte féréole
d'un tout petit bled en corrèze et la
coutume dit que quand on est élu au
conseil municipal pour la première fois
ont fait un grand buffet campagnard on
amène toutes les victuailles pour éviter
tout le vrai tout le village alors je
voyais chirac y préparer tout ça moi je
l'aidais un petit peu à tout mais dans
sa 403 et la touche du bois madame
chirac qui ne bouge pas je dis madame
vous n'allez pas ce soir avec votre mari
à sainte féréole elle a eu cette phrase
définitive
non jamais je ne laisserai jacques faire
de la politique
et elle a été ensuite un grand supporter
de de son mari j'ai cru dès le début
donc il avait 28 ans que ce quelqu'un
qui reste très loin
peut-être parce qu'ils avaient ce
ce côté très très mordant très
très personnelle en fin de
en forme en plus les étudiants et serra
et
j'ai pas été en fait j'ai pas été
surpris j'ai suivi beaucoup sa carrière
après j'ai revu dans un temps mais pas
autant que j'aurais même et j'ai vu de
même de temps en temps mais ils avaient
vraiment
comment dire il a vu mais on a senti dès
le début qu'il allait se passer quelque
chose avec ce bonhomme s'était pas juste
d'un politique comme un autre et ceci
fait que j'ai suivi un peu sa carrière à
matignon
également les soucis qu'il a eus je suis
allé deux fois en corrèze et dans sa
maison et je me souviens de c'était
l'époque où
giscard de m
oui je crois était président de la
république et il m'avait dit j'avais dit
mais vous allez vous présenter au
prochain coup et cetera il m'a dit oh je
ne sais pas toutes façons giscard il a
mis la barre sur ses talons
donc et puis il avait ses charmants
petits châteaux ou très modestes en
corrèze et donc c'était
on s'attendait à ce qu'il se passe
quelque chose un gars comme ça c'était
pas quelqu'un de deux légers
voilà il était très
très très costaud politiquement
regost au début on a vu qu'il ya des
problèmes bien sûr les cet accident de
voiture qu'il a un moment les élections
européennes qui l'a gêné il est il a
aidé des gros problèmes ou sinon dans la
vie sa part été quelque chose s'est
passé n'est pas été un long fleuve
tranquille il a et il est toujours
arriver finalement à retomber sur ses
pattes
il ya finalement être élu président la
république il était fidèle en amitié moi
j'ai la chance que il m'est donnée
la croix de chevalier les gens d'honneur
et la croix d'officier légion d'honneur
à l'elysée ce qui fait qu'à ce moment là
vous n'êtes pas obligé de faire des
discours c'est le président qui fait un
discours et après le récipiendaire a
fait pas de source parce que c'est très
délicat de dire je suis un mec
formidable j'ai fait si j'ai fait ça moi
ça me déplaisait outrageusement et je
vais revus à l'elysée dans différentes
manifestations
de temps à autre
c'est clair alors c'est curieux jacques
chirac il disait qu'il y avait beaucoup
de talent il n'y avait pas beaucoup de
même de mémoire c'est très curieux c'est
quand il fait des discours souvent ils
avaient un papier
vous l'avez remarqué sur noir et
il n'était pas voilà il n'avait pas une
mémoire comme comme françois mitterrand
j'ai un tout petit peu connue aussi
qu'il y avait une mémoire mais
phénoménal